I mean that's cliche but something
rather than just freaking out the ball
is just like no don't do it what do you
think he would do and then we did it
anyway what have we done
[Music]
[Music]
so far it's been tough yeah yeah I mean
that like after 340 that grinds brutal
oh hey hello yeah I know the grind is
real I had those same 30-minute heroic
strikes last night I think it's just
like they're kind of catering to the
hardcore again I feel like they kind of
went to like general population destiny
to came out and then now they're like
well you know the only people really
still playing our game I feel like are
the hardcore so we might as well try to
appease them and then come September
maybe that's when we're like hey
everyone you should play destiny I do
wish there was something more in the
middle though because like the actual
story is super like accessible and I
hadn't played in forever and I went from
3:10 to 337 like in two hours but then
after that there's a steep drop-off of
oh this public event is 380 or this
heroic strike is 30 minutes long like
there needs to be a little more of a gap
that's been destiny to use problem
to be fair there they're tackling in
this time around I note a and I had some
conversations about two but ever since
sc2 launched A's crew was doing raids
and I was getting all the benefits of it
and that felt a little bit weird they
were so afraid to offend casual players
like you're not as good as tape it
honestly tastes better than me at this
game and he raids and I don't and like
any mechanic that allows data to do
something that I can't is cool and and
it's okay for a casual player to walk in
and see what a hardcore player has and
be impressed by it so it's nice it feels
like it's a little bit tougher this time
around yeah I think it's definitely
gonna be harder for the casual players
this time around I feel like only
because it's like okay you have a story
it takes about 90 minutes it's like four
missions or something like that yeah and
like after that it's like I guess we're
doing milestones cuz like there are some
quests after that you know are a little
bit more involved and they're more
grindy it's like okay I know sleeper
simulant which is like the really cool
fusion exists here's like a six part
class that you have to do but like some
of those parts of those quests are gonna
be pretty time-consuming especially if
you're playing solo you know like the
hand cannon you to get precision shots
that's just the first step
yeah and then you like you have to kill
powerful enemies and then you have to
find a sleeper no there's like a lot of
things that you have to do and I kind of
like it but at the same time it's weird
to see them shift the balance right like
it wasn't trying to find the middle
ground or something for you know casuals
and hardcore players it's really kind of
going back like I said earlier to just
shifting to the hardcore players
I don't know maybe that's good enough
for now but at least exotics are fun the
exotics are really fun they're really
good I like the Kravitz and Lance
changes a lot so I was like I liked it
before but that that like bigger
explosion and like but look the thunk of
it is it feels so good
but there's a bunch of good ones like
wrist garters really good now man
conductor so much better
sky burgers oath there's actually a
reason to use it now I always thought
that that exotic was really good but
because everything is so much harder now
one of the really cool benefits of
exotics being particularly useful is
they have a reason for them you were
saying like risk runner is gives you a
lot of resilience to arc damage
so with these heroic strikes being so
much tougher bring it back around if
you're ever fighting the fall and you
have a reason to have risk runner or if
you're fighting cabal you have a reason
to have sky burners it's really cool but
because the game is difficult again and
because the exotics are so much better
there's now a reason to just use them
rather than just run through everything
and try and get to the end
but I don't know man like I was joking
before the game came out for before the
DLC came out that was like I'll be back
for like a week or two and I'm super
excited again and like as I'm doing the
grind and as some of my friends that
used to play more regularly aren't
playing it's like really tough just keep
staying motivated and it's only been a
day
but then again I'm playing it at a very
like fast pace that most people probably
wouldn't play at so it's like
maybe if I took it more casually all
these things seem a little bit more
interesting I don't know it's it's a lot
of the things that destiny has been
doing like like things that we've
already burned through but it's just
like a different adventure like I've
done adventures this is just a one
that's on a different part of Mars like
it's not like it's if you really liked
those things I think it's like here
remember why you like destiny but wait
for the really big changes you know like
that's how I feel about war mine is like
it's a house of rules and destiny
this time around two of the strikes are
just from the campaign again yep pretty
much there's one where you fight like a
hive wizard he's actually the son of
Oryx which is kind of cool
and the other one is the worm guy
I do think the world God fights pretty
cool I like that worm God he's freaky
yeah I mean I think the funny thing is I
think I read on reddit to that like
somebody was mentioning like that's
twice now Bungie that like you've made n
story mission bosses like the final boss
of the story campaign like not like raid
like bosses cuz they're like big grand
spectacles almost write like you're
fighting Gul on this huge ship or you're
fighting this giant worm that's like
crashing into the ground why not make
that like a raid moment yeah I think the
counter is that I forget the percentage
but I remember them talking at the
beginning when destiny 2 is launching
that like most players don't even
experience the raid so I do think it's
like oh we're gonna save our big
cinematic spectacle moments for
something that most players will see
down a warm cot it's really weird how
much they'd stay away from consequences
which is what we get to attach two
characters and spoilers
you know Rasputin wakes up and Anna has
a one second where she's like what did I
do
and then literally two minutes later
she's saying to the player don't worry
about it I'm sure it'll all be fine I
know without a question that no matter
what comes next we can face it together
just destroying that conflict it would
be such a more interesting story if she
was freaked out that she just woke up
Rasputin realize that her family that
created him really created that research
facility like actually it was evil good
thing I know a few tricks at least that
seems to run in the family I mean that's
cliche but something rather than just
like no don't do it what do you think he
would do and then we did it anyway what
have we done and then he was like okay
he's supposed to be like the head
commander too which is the kind of funny
[Music]
we've got this
so the big question at the end of the
day is do you guys think this is enough
to keep you happy until the next DLC a
lot of it from me personally will be can
I get my rate group back together even
if it's for like once a week because
like that was that was fun for me right
like I knew that like on this day it's
like alright cool we're all gonna jump
on at 7:00 we're gonna play together you
know destiny was just kind of like the
vehicle to get us to play a game
together and so if I can get them back I
think I'll be on it longer but if they
don't play then how am I gonna do rate
layer outside of like trying to do it
looking for group or maybe trying to
scrounge everyone in the office to do it
or how am I gonna do escalation protocol
which is like a380 power light and your
power level comes along that you know I
think in another week or two it will
gradually get easier but there's like
seven waves of that and people are
struggling with the first way you know
so we'll see for me it's like more about
can I get my friends back into it what
about for you Kelly for me I mean like
the thing I like most about destiny is
actually just the way the shooting feels
like it is my favorite like mechanically
my favorite shooting in games right now
and I think like updating the exotics
which is just you know part of this part
of the update isn't really cool I loved
playing around with them like I'm really
enjoying that but I don't know I just
feel like none of the carrots are really
attractive to me I just I don't know I
need something more I need something
more like more transformative it's like
the hive there ice hive they shatter
when you kill them like they're still
high
I mean it's cliche but I am waiting for
the taking key moment or it's like oh
here's just a totally different
dimension to this game that you didn't
even know could be there like hey I need
more of that because it just feels the
same except in the basin instead of in
another area of what we've already had
why you an I'll pretty much play as long
as you play when there's it's like you
said it's a social game when there's
people in the office to play with I'll
play otherwise I'm probably any go
finish go to war that's totally fair
[Music]